[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en real 24 y es hora de ir a nuestra
sección cinco minutos con hoy nos
acompaña a jairo yáñez alcalde de cúcuta
en colombia un departamento de constante
comunicación en constante contacto con
venezuela por encontrarse justamente en
la frontera entre ambas naciones
bienvenido señor yáñez a france 24
cuéntenos colombia se prepara para una
posible reapertura de uno de los pasos
fronterizos más importantes entre
colombia y venezuela cuáles son las
principales preocupaciones de las
autoridades encargadas de esta
reapertura en generacción muchas las
inquietudes que tenemos respecto de una
apertura sin los suficientes estudios
previos y los análisis sobre todo desde
el punto de vista de la identificación
del registro lamentablemente los
venezolanos que quieren acceder la
república de colombia no tienen
pasaporte no tienen identificación y
obviamente a partir de este momento todo
necesariamente le
fundamenta una gran preocupación por eso
ese es quizá uno de los mayores temas
dedicados por ahora la frontera está
cerrada y las trochas son el día a día
de esta ciudad y generan obviamente
todos los riesgos de contagio todas las
situaciones
digamos críticas de inseguridad porque
las condiciones humanitarias de los
venezolanos que atraviesan la contra en
ese momento son bastante críticas de
darse una apertura sería preferible un
análisis previo como mínimo de una
comunicación binacional al menos entre
las autoridades civiles para tratar de
hacer una mejor planeación hay muchas
personas que van a demandar
permanentemente servicios a buscar
asistencia médica a buscar productos de
alimentos de primera necesidad pero
todos estos temas estamos muy muy
interesados y ya un poco a poco en mesas
de trabajo con el autogobierno
hemos venido perfilando estrategias en
este sentido
alcalde usted está en cúcuta capital del
departamento colombiano de norte de
santander uno de los departamentos con
mayor porcentaje de venezolanos
población que en algunos casos vive ya
en colombia y otra que es flotante que
va y viene continuamente por temas de
trabajo cuéntenos qué medidas se van a
tomar en las fronteras con venezuela
para evitar la propagación del virus
entre ambas naciones hay tres
básicamente tres acciones permanentes la
búsqueda activa comunican ya no se acosa
epidemiológicos y una estrategia de
permanente de control de tiempo de las
rápidas y un cuarto factor fundamental
que es un tema de pedagogía permanente
en los espacios de mayor congestión como
todos sabemos los los sitios donde hay
mayor congestión son los sitios más
críticos estos sitios críticos hay que
comportarnos a partir de
estrategias pedagógicas estrategias de
marcación del espacio público sobre todo
para el tema de vendedores ambulantes
que en caso de cúcuta es una de las
principales apuestas de cultura
ciudadana y naturalmente de mayor
preocupación alcalde pero además en caso
de que esta reapertura se dé en usted
como justamente alcalde de conjunta
sería el encargado por las autoridades
nacionales de gerenciar esta reapertura
este sería el gerente dar la apertura
fronteriza con venezuela con tenemos que
apoyo le están prestando las autoridades
nacionales para que sus estrategias
puedan llevarse a cabo de la mejor
manera el diálogo el diálogo permanente
interinstitucional yo creo que el
diálogo con la gobernación del
departamento por la oficina de migración
colombia con la representación directa
del presidente de la república en estas
mesas de trabajo a través de la gerencia
de fronteras yo creo que el diálogo
constructivo siempre estará sobre el
sobre
sobre la mesa estamos desarrollando la
estrategia que desde conjunta queremos
liderar injerencia esta gerencia
estratégica por la apertura de la mano
con los empresarios de la mano con toda
la institucionalidad para entender que
convocar necesita la apertura conjunta
necesita cambiar la identificación que
se tiene a nivel internacional de que
somos una ciudad solamente identificada
por la crisis humanitaria venezuela no
buscando acceso cúcuta es una ciudad que
pretende con base en la apuesta
importantísima con la educación con las
reconversiones sociales económicas
ocupan de nuevo los sitios que se merece
pues agradecemos la presencia de jairo
yáñez alcalde de cúcuta ciudad de
colombia en la frontera con venezuela
por estar aquí entradas 24 en 5 minutos
con alcalde gracias por estar con
nosotros y por contarnos las estrategias
para la posible reapertura de la
frontera
ok ustedes muy amables y también ustedes
gracias por estar en france 24 ustedes
pueden también continuar con más
información en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom información en inglés
francés árabe español y por supuesto con
más de nuestra programación quédense con
nosotros esto es france24
[Música]